brian schottenheimer a day after pete
carroll the coach of the seahawks
created a vague indication no changes
were going to be made a change was made
schottenheimer out gone
i think these tweets
look just i mean can we put that back up
i i
i understand that that
i mean the guy got fired brian shawnam
is a fantastic person in coach and we
thank him for the last three years
citing philosophical differences we have
parted ways you fired him just own it it
doesn't work anymore
he's gone and i don't know what the
philosophical differences are this year
was about placating russell wilson and
letting at least it started that way
letting russell wilson develop and
flourish as a quarterback and he did
through september and into october until
he didn't
and i i feel like pete carroll whose
head was was gradually emerging from the
shell
after the way things went offensively in
the second half of the season he sucked
his head back into the shell and it's
going to be run the ball run the ball
run the ball like it was in the earlier
days it's like we're no longer going to
build the team around russell wilson
we're going to try to go back to what we
had in 2012 2013 2014 where it was
strong defense strong running game and
quarterback who who added to
these broader
and more important in the eyes of pete
carroll objectives that's where i feel
like this is going in seattle now and
that may mean russell wilson ain't going
to be there well it does it is it seems
like it's going that way but everything
you hear from pete carroll definitely
it's all he knows that's what he is
you know that's part of being a
defensive coach
pete carroll again another one of those
that's you know one of the great coaches
of our era you know in the history of
football whatever you want to say he's
great if he had one flaw i would tell
you he doesn't know
how to hire offensive coordinators that
would be the issue you know he's never
been around a great offensive
coordinator yet that knows how to dice
people up for four and five at eight and
ten and twenty five and blah blah blah
blah yeah you know so he just goes oh
wait i i don't know when we try to
become a passing team it doesn't always
work well yeah it doesn't work not
because of like you know russell wilson
or that it's because
you know brian schottenheimer's offense
lacks creativity or schematical
advantages for the football players or
you know
anything new on a weekly basis we heard
darius williams talk about on the pick
six on the screen as soon as he came in
motion i knew what the play was that's
been a thing in seattle it was the thing
in the super bowl 49 against the
patriots i mean you could ask some of my
friends when they lined up in that
formation i knew they were running that
play but that was daryl bevel i know but
i'm just making the broader point that
offense has never been
creative there it's been an issue
altogether and yeah the fact of how they
looked at the end of the year and how
some of these defenses shut down russell
the way he looked dk metcalf couldn't
get the ball
i understand that and pete's going to
revert back to going whoa my defense
played good at the end of the year let's
get better at running the ball and i
know how i got the two super bowls
already how about i just do that again
it's trying to instead of trying to do
something that i've never really done
which is become the air show you know
don coryell style
the real question as i see it is whether
or not russell wilson in a bout of
self-awareness realizes that
he's better off
flashing
moments of high-end ability in that kind
of an offensive scheme than having
himself be the centerpiece because it's
the centerpiece it didn't work now maybe
it's schottenheimer's fault that him
being the centerpiece didn't work see
that's the other side and these
quarterbacks that's what i would say
he's not going to show up and say he's
he's not going to show up and say
okay i just okay fine you let me have
the keys of the car and i drove it into
a tree he's going to say the guy who
designed the car didn't know what he was
doing you get me a better car designer
i'm going to drive that that car all the
way to the championship so this this is
why i feel like it's heading in a bad
way what i was told earlier in the year
when we were talking about let russ cook
it was let rose cooker he's going to
find a new kitchen well they let him
cook it didn't work and now i feel like
what pete carroll is saying is the hell
with this we're going to do it my way
and that's going to set the stage for a
potential showdown with russell wilson
and again folks we're just trying to get
you ahead of the curve here as to where
the ball is moving and it may be moving
in a direction of wilson moving out of
seattle and i know cox fans
find it incomprehensible could ever
happen although based on how he played
late in the year maybe some
won't be upset about it but but
this move
sets the stage now if they hire an
offensive coordinator who's going to
throw the ball all over the place and
let russell wilson become patrick with
homes or josh allen or aaron rodgers
fine but that's not what pete carroll's
going to do let's listen to pete carroll
talking about his desire that they run
the ball not just better but that they
run the ball more
we don't have it right now
but that's what he said
now we do have it pete
pete go ahead and play it pete get your
crap straight pete i will share this
with you that we have to run the ball
better and and not not even better we
have to run out more and and that's to
we have to dictate what's going on uh
with the people that we're playing and
that's one of the ways to do that and i
know the fans aren't real jacked about
hearing that but uh um but russ knows it
too you know we need to we need to be
able to knock those guys into the scheme
that we want to throw at and uh
which was happening more earlier in the
season and so we took full advantage of
it
okay that's pete carroll but he just
said it there on the ball we need to
knock those guys into the looks we want
to throw against right so they're just
they're basically saying look we don't
know how to figure out how to get guys
open unless we just run the ball and now
you have to come up and now it's one on
one and our jimmies and our joes will
beat you one-on-one that's what they've
become that's what they are you know
there's never that you've heard me say
before mike you know i russell wasn't
great down the stretch but i am going to
sit here and blame the offense more than
i am russell wilson that's for sure
you've heard me say in some of our pix
pods they waste plays they run passes
against two deep coverages where i go
i don't know i mean john gruden josh
mcdaniels bill belichick
jeff fisher they would tell you you'd
never run this play against too deep
coverage but they would just run it and
go hey we'll figure it out russ figure
it out and none of the other great
quarterbacks have to do that you know so
there's a there is there is there's been
issues with that offense and it stalled
down the stretch because they played
some good defenses but played some
coaches who understood how to break it
down and it's just too it's too easy of
an offense to break down in seattle
especially in the passing game and you
just saw that last week the rams were
all over everything and then i knew mike
i knew the rams were all over everything
because they are a team that wants to
rush four right we know they have that
great pass rush they started rushing
five because they went ah we don't need
the extra guy back in pass coverage we
got it locked up we don't need it let's
send another guy at russ so he can't
scramble and make some crazy play like
he beat us within week 16.
and yeah there has to be adjustments
there to go to the running thing sorry
i'm blabbering last thing
that's fine i mean that could work it
could make russell happy i mean when you
look at the top offenses in football the
titans the vikings the packers you know
even the tampa bay buccaneers it's all
about run and play action pass and throw
the ball down the field so if they can
find a way to do that russell could be
very happy in that system as well
well i think that for now it's a let's
wait and see what occurs russell wilson
is still under contract and maybe he
gives it another year before he starts
thinking is this really working but
let's get look pete carroll's been a
great head coach
he's getting
if not already in firm hall of fame
conversation pretty damn close to it
when you consider his accomplishments in
seattle over the past decade
but man this inability to get an
offensive coordinator who can maximize
who can really be creative who can find
ways to to get the ball to dk metcalf
short of let's just run the ball and
hope we can get play action and get him
in a one-on-one matchup on the outside
right that that's not that that's this
gets back to my point from earlier about
robert salah
in this
even
even though there is still a huge
significance of good defense in the nfl
and and you need to have that i just i
feel like to be successful year in and
year out you need to have an offensive
head coach who's always pushing the
envelope thinking of new ways of doing
things staying ahead of the defenses
it's not the defenses that stay ahead of
the offenses it's the offenses that stay
ahead of the defenses and i think that's
why it's it's critical to have someone
who can do that and if your head coach
is a defensive specialist
he better have somebody there who can
stay ahead of the curve offensively and
not be behind the trends and the things
that are working for other teams uh one
other thing about the seahawks john
schneider has signed an extension he'll
be there at least through the 2027 draft
boo yeah a thing
the lions they were going to hire him
and they they they weren't going to have
to compensate the seahawks and because
he doesn't have final say i i'm sorry i
don't know how to put it other than to
say that was baloney well i got some
other words that start with b but that
that just
because you know what chris they still
could
this new contract doesn't mean anything
right unless they've given him final say
instead of pete carroll if that's the
standard that's not the standard that
was that was dead on arrival you can't
hire john schneider without basically
doing a trade for john schneider that
was never going to happen and it still
could it still could if the lions really
want him it still could and i just think
that was that was aimed i had 20
different people tell me when that story
came out this is a a leverage play to
get schneider the contract he wants with
the seahawks and he got it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports